Most countries have a central bank that manages the money supply...
...and is independent from the government to prevent political interference.
The government can implement many types of economic policy,...
...like decreasing people's taxes and creating jobs through public infrastructure projects.
But it actually can't just increase the money supply.
The central bank determines how much money is in circulation at a time.
So, why can't central banks authorize the printing of unlimited money...
...to help an economy in crisis?
They could, but that's a short-term solution...
...that doesn't necessarily boost economic growth in the long term...
...and can actually hurt the economy.
Why?
With more money in circulation, manufacturers of goods like food, clothing, and cars...
...could respond to demand simply by raising prices...
...rather than manufacturing more of these goods...
...and creating new jobs in the process.
This would mean you could no longer buy as much with the same amount of money,...
...a situation known as inflation.
A little bit of inflation, about 2% a year,...
...is considered a sign of economic health but more can quickly derail an economy.